[Music]
rusty is kicking us off he's in
mansfield ohio rusty welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thanks for having me uh thanks for
taking my call absolutely and so i
i'm getting ready to graduate college
here
um in may
and uh i'll be a pharmacist once i pass
my boards
i'm 36 my wife's 32
i have a whole bunch of student loan
debt about three hundred and forty two
thousand dollars in student loan debt
whoa um i have
yeah i have about nine thousand in
credit cards
and we have about thirty four thousand
tied up in cars
and then i have a personal loan
from a family member which kind of
includes a house they put down their
house as
collateral with a balloon loan so we've
just been paying the interest to kind of
live here
how much how much is
that um the house is only 51 000 but in
total with other money i owe it's about
97 98 000
so what's the total debt that you owe
482 000. oh
rusty
how are you feeling are you okay
oh yeah i'm all right i'm more worried
than you are listening to your show
about a year ago and uh
you know i felt like i needed to pursue
the pretty big shovel because i was
almost done with school so
i have a job lined up i'll start
how much are you going to be making my
boards
i'll be making 108 000.
and that's i have a job that'll be seven
days on and seven days off so i plan on
picking up another job good good you
know yep awesome yep is that your
household income or is there more money
um my wife brings home about uh
450 a week so
what is she doing what is that what does
that pan out to anything she'll make
this year
um she just started this job a few
months ago so i'm gonna say maybe around
30 to 35 somewhere in that range what is
she doing
uh she's a customer service wrestler
is that full time
yes okay do you guys have kids
um we do not that's something else i
kind of want to throw in there um
so she we have issues so we'll probably
have to do like an ivf if we want to
have kids
so um i wasn't sure if
you know where that would fit in either
because yeah we're getting kind of older
and it's coming towards that time or not
at all so totally
wow so how can we help today
um i just i just kind of need a plan of
i guess where to start
um
so the house doesn't have to be
refinanced for another three to four
years
before
they call for that bloom loan so i
wasn't sure if i should pay on other
stuff for three years or so you get out
of this house situation yeah
is it is it the house that you're living
in that has the mortgage and the loan
and everything or is it
the family members oh
um
my mother put her house as collateral
for this house because this house is
technically worth a little bit more so
it's her house that
is on the line i guess
and how much do you have left how much
is left on the house
oh we've just been paying the interest
so the whole amount
rusty you're gonna have to get how much
will it sell for
um i honestly don't know because here's
the deal rusty y'all are 17. sagan
we we got it in 2017 so it's been a
little while i'm sure it's probably
when this market went up a little bit
but yeah yeah probably has so here's the
thing rusty you're in kind of a extreme
situation with everything going on in
the amount
of debt which means in order to make
movement you're going to have to make
some extreme moves and we don't always
recommend selling a home and that kind
of thing um to get out of debt cause for
some people it's like hey you got twelve
thousand dollars of credit card debt and
we're like awesome cut everything and
pay it off as fast as possible but you i
mean it's a substantial amount almost
half a million dollars and so if you
want to start making some big moves
that's where i'm going to start looking
first and foremost it's like where are
the places that we can make some
jurassic moves um
and i know you guys want a family in the
future and that's amazing and we can
definitely talk about that later on in
this call but like you don't have kids
right now nothing's tying you down to
this hat like i would start eliminating
stuff and your cars you got thirty four
thousand dollars a car debt how is that
between both cars or is that yes yeah
that's between those between both cars
what are the cars worth
um
so we owe about a little over ten
thousand on one it's probably worth
about 12 or 13.
and then we have about 23.7 on the other
one and it's about 25 worth 25 or 26.
okay
well
man if i'm in your shoes i'm feeling
feeling a sense of urgency and i'm going
we are selling these cars tomorrow and
we're going to drive beater cars we are
selling this house
next month and we are going to live
somewhere that we can afford one bedroom
tiny apartment i mean like i mean i'm
talking yes making these experiences
this is an emergency situation and the
nine thousand dollar credit card all of
it so like russell yes what george is
saying and i totally agree with like
there needs to be this sense of okay in
order to make a dent in half a million
dollars of debt we got to just make some
moves and so that's right selling the
car selling the house and then mapping
out a game plan so you're going to make
108k
um
a year but then that's every other week
so finding a job asap of what you can do
every other week your wife's making 35
000 in this market honestly i think she
can make more i would be looking for a
different job like i would be upping i
would be making huge lifestyle changes
because when you do that what's going to
end up happening is you're going to
you're going to have all this other
margin to throw at the debt you're not
going to you guys are going to be living
on nothing everything's going to be
going towards that because if you're not
making these types of decisions you're
going to be in this for a really long
time and your pattern so far rusty not
to shame you but your patterns so far of
the decisions you guys have made with
the credit card debt the car loans your
mom taking out you know clatter on her
house with a balloon mortgage like
your whole mindset has to shift like you
have to have this realization what we've
done
has not worked so we're actually gonna
have to do the opposite of everything i
thought i was gonna do with money and so
it you and your wife together like
making this because what i would do too
is and sorry george you can jump in but
like is having your why what's your why
and for you guys to start a family and
yes and i and we've had close dear
friends go through this process multiple
friends go through the ivf process and
it's long it's exhausting it's strenuous
it's set i mean there's all that emotion
and then obviously the prayer of being
able to have a family on the other side
of that
i want that to be your why like
like sacrificing so majorly to say over
here is what we want our lives to be in
order to do that so well as stress-free
as possible with as much money in the
bank
these are the decisions we have to make
yeah and make sure you're cash flowing
that ivf treatment don't go into debt
for it which means we got to clean this
thing up and use that why
listen your life at this rate is going
to suck for 10 to 20 years i don't want
that for you i wanted to suck for two
years because you got gazelle intense
you sacrificed you did everything you
could for your family for that future
kid that's what i want for you rusty i'm
gonna gift you one year of ramsay plus i
want you and your wife to go through all
the financial peace university videos
get a game plan get on the every dollar
budget and start attacking this thing
with a vengeance because your life
depends on